Speaker 1: All right. I now
I'm glad I genuinely am glad
to be able to do what so many of you delightful
MAGA people have been telling me I should do.
Talk about the Biden crimes. Talk about the Biden
crimes. Let's talk about them. Donald trump was
indicted on 3437 felony counts last week. And on
that day you had fox with a front page headline
about the Biden bribery and you had Trump speaking
at Bedminster talking about Biden's documents and
all of these different things. So let's talk
a little bit about it. We're going to talk
about later about some of the allegations made by
Republicans that Joe Biden has committed crimes.
That doesn't really sound like due process
to me, but we'll get to that in a moment.
But let's talk about the new bombshell about
Biden bribery. If you actually questioned
Republicans specifically about what they are
alleging here, you get them mostly to admit
they don't know whether the Biden bribery tapes
actually exist. They haven't spoken to one of
the main people making these allegations in
three years. Even those who are sure the tapes
exist say they actually don't know if they are
reputable or trustworthy. So let's talk about
Biden bribery. And you are very quickly going
to realize as of right now, there isn't anything
that we would call evidence on the day of Trump's
indictment. So many of you wrote to me and said,
why won't. I talk about this? Well, it's not that
I won't talk about it. It's that we actually need
to know. Is there anything worthy of talking
about? Here is Republican Congressman James Comer,
not sandbagged by some left wing interviewer, but
interviewed on Newsmax. And he says the tapes.
The tapes. Everybody is building this case around.
He's not even sure if those tapes are legitimate.
Speaker 2: When will you be able
to confirm if these recordings are
legit? How long is that going to take?
Speaker 3: Well, I can confirm that the
recordings were in the 1023, remember? Okay.
Speaker 1: Let's pause it right there.
The 1023. The 1023 they are referring to is a
form that asserts the existence of such tapes.
It is not evidence of the tapes. What he says
is the form mentions the tapes. That's like if
I make a statement and I. I could write down on
this piece of paper down here that Hunter Biden's
laptop is actually, you know, a Nintendo. We the
fact that I've written it down doesn't mean that
it is true. Okay. But let's continue.
Speaker 3: Senator Grassley,
when we saw the unredacted version.
Speaker 2: Okay. So because Grassley
was saying alleged yesterday,
so these recordings are legit,
you can confirm they are legitimate.
Speaker 3: Well, they were I can
confirm they were listed in the 1023.
Speaker 1: That you understand that,
right? He he he can't confirm that these
recordings are legitimate. He can just say
they are referred to on a piece of paper.
Speaker 3: The FBI redacted. I don't know
if they're legit or not, but we know that
the foreign national claims he has them.
Speaker 1: Exactly. We don't know if they are
legitimate. This is the blockbuster that so many
of our MAGA viewers are saying I'm ignoring. Okay.
Here is James Comber saying they haven't heard
from the so-called major witness in three years.
Speaker 3: With respect to the tapes. Look,
it mentioned in the FBI form that the oligarch had
17 tapes of Biden, two with Joe Biden accepting
the bribe that he used that as in ensuring.
Speaker 2: This this oligarch is a
high ranking, was a high ranking.
Speaker 3: Member or owner of Burisma.
Yes, that is exactly right. So have you had any
conversation with him? Unfortunately, nobody's had
any contact with him for the last three years.
Speaker 1: Okay. So the blockbuster that I
ignored on the day Trump was indicted in an
extraordinarily detailed and tight indictment,
per Chris Christie, that that day I am guilty
of ignoring the blockbuster story in which
a supposed Russian oligarch who hasn't
been heard from for three years asserted,
according to a 1023 form, that he has tapes which
we don't know exist. And even if they exist,
we don't know if they are legitimate tapes. Here
is Marjorie Taylor GREENE also admitting it.
The audio is poor. She's speaking to CNN's Manu
Raju here. But listen closely to what she says.
Speaker 2: So that guy is really hurting
her. And so we need to find out that because
I don't think I'm going to.
Speaker 1: Find that out.
Okay. So she first says these audio recordings
that were made are a really big deal.
Now, does the guy have the audio recordings? I
don't know. And I don't think we're going to find
out. Wow. That is really quite a story, Marjorie.
Really, really unbelievable. And then when you
actually go through a lot of the reporting on
this, you see that there is a lot of shakiness,
shakiness. The Daily Beast reporting Republicans
admit they don't know if the Biden bribery tapes
really exist. Newsmax had an article earlier this
week of Congressman Waltz saying that a blind eye
is being turned to the Biden documents. We're not
even really sure that the Biden documents refer
to things that exist. You have an article from the
New York Post Burisma Boss in Alleged Biden bribes
scheme claims to have 15 taped conversations
with Hunter and two with Joe, according to Chuck
Grassley. Is Chuck Grassley telling the truth? Is
the guy actually a Burisma boss? Did he actually
claim to have those tapes? Do the tapes exist?
Are the tapes legitimate? Do the tapes even expose
the alleged criminality they claim is there?
And then also Fox News reporting Burisma,
audiotapes could be could be a cataclysmic
event for President Biden, according to Trump's
completely weaponized and delusional former acting
AG Matt Whitaker. There is very little here,
my friends. The Hunter Biden laptop. Okay, the
laptop maybe is real. There were three MacBooks
dropped off by someone to a blind repairman who
couldn't actually see who's they were. But he
saw a sticker on one of the Mac books for Beau
Biden's charity and said, This is Hunter Biden's
laptop. It didn't really contain much other
than some extraordinarily vague, unsubstantiated
reference and explicit pictures of Hunter Biden
himself. Not exactly a major blockbuster story.
The Biden bribery tapes. Do they actually exist?
We don't really know right now. The Biden, quote,
classified documents scandal. Let's suspend that
one for now because I'll dig into it a little bit
later. And then Hillary's crimes, of course, she
was cleared of criminal wrongdoing and we'll talk
about that later. The one thing out of all of
this that I can tell you is real is that there
is a real 37 count federal felony indictment
against Donald Trump. It contains photographic
evidence. It refers to audio recordings. It
is extraordinarily tight, according to Chris
Christie. That is real, that we know exists. But
these MAGA people keep writing to me and saying,
David, you're not willing to talk about X, Y,
Z. I'm glad to talk about it when I have time.
Like today, there's just really not that much
to say about it. And that's the reason I'm not
giving it more coverage. Remember that the David
Parkman show is an audience supported program.
We're really a community funded show, unlike
so many of those other right wing and even some
centrist and center left media outlets, we really
depend primarily on your support. You can sign up
at join Pacman dot com. We really do put in a
lot of effort both technologically and in terms
of staff time into providing great perks for our
members, including commercial free audio and video
streams of every day's show. An extra program
every weekday called the bonus show Access to a
Soundboard that works like my soundboard here.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money. Yeah, everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is back.
Speaker 1: We have a soundboard like
that software version available in the
membership portion of the website as well as
invites to member only town halls you can sign
up at join Pacman dot com and of course use
the now infamous coupon code indicted again.